There's some great dishes that are made
And Rose, you already touched on that
favorite meal or dishes be all i know
mine i could have mine if it's in a thai
green curry I i can i can be anything if
I can eat poo poos if it was in a green
curry i love green card huh
I'm right battered and deep-fried
comparative beaver pappardelle pasta
some brain Raghu there
yeah probably working with the some
macaroni and cheese
yeah it's a bacon bits bring bit that's
all right i think i do nachos with some
brains on top
yeah i would do brain charge on huh
shoutout to my vowels tell hands
yeah I would probably do the turkey
brine chili
been there done that intelligence will
go back two seconds
alright thanks thanks thank you
has anybody else dressed up in that
before you the only 1i haven't seen any
but it's all God yeah we all go to you
how you come to bring a hand we got the
same detail is awesome thanks
now I'm flustered oh my question was
actually about in the finale about
Natalie she was taken away for them to
you know try some cure thing on her and
that's the last we hear of her we don't
see her or anything so i was wondering
if she's if that's gonna come back into
play at all or if that's the end
uh yeah it comes back into play
in as we start season three major is
right back on the hunt for Natalie he
wants to figure that out he feels like
he made a promise to her that he did not
keep and he wants to fix that
thank you whoa alright
hi my name is Amy and I'm from Carson
City Nevada and obviously I'm a big I
zombie fan but i'm also a big harry
potter fan and I'm part of the hogwarts
running club and one of the things we do
is sort of ourselves into the houses so
i was wondering if any of you identify
as belonging to a particular house
slurry mall the house of the range would
be Gryffindor Slytherin what plane and
Slytherin thank you about Anders and
sweater and now both of whom I actually
did the soaring how it said slytherin
but I feel Gryffindor by says I'm
slytherin what you mean there's a test
now you were to happen
yeah i talked about on your end I come
on this week is is there is there like a
huff and puff powerful book yeah okay
i'll be back often and how that's not a
house a girlfriend or his grip and all
right there Gryffindor from yeah i be
pregnant you know what are you what are
you by the you but what do you identify
yourself as darlin carson city i'm a
ravenclaw
hi we are you got popular answer much
more popular than a person yeah i'm a
red metal that to people
yes hello
hi I'm sandy I'm from Austin Texas
I had a question four rows or anybody
else who wanted to answer and that's if
lives abilities have given any of you
inside on human nature or like how
different everyday is that you maybe
didn't have before you started the show
eat i actually found the one brain I've
enjoyed all the brains different things
about each of them that a like whether
it's learning a physical skill or
humorous or something there's always
something to enjoy and the 1i didn't
enjoy playing was the start of season 2
episode 1 where I was like that she
banca bigoted Rice's kind of brain and
it was actually probably quite a good
exercise because you know you tend to
hear these tirades that these people say
and feel so strongly like that I just
don't want to engage or think about it
and in a weird way it was it was
definitely kind of like I didn't I
didn't enjoy that episode to film like I
really i found it quite upsetting but
thinking about like trying to understand
when people come from and where they
kind of conditioning of their minds
comes from and you know this guy's in
chronic pain and maybe that's changed
his outlook on the world I think like
especially given certain things that are
going on at the moment like it's very
important to to like try and understand
we're thinking that you disagree with
comes from rather than I'm just shutting
your mind doing yeah so that's mine
I I learned a lot I was really touched
in connected most with a stripper brain
really changed how I go about my day to
day life I tell you actually were
filming a strip club and alli and I what
you're very professional and having to
do all the staff and there's lots of
amazing dancers around us that is the
only day in two seasons of shooting that
role volunteered to come down and just
check everybody was going ok enough make
sure that I know we're all well fed and
coffee and water and it was very present
which was strange role actually I do
tell you one thing about stripper grain
is that there's a ride through a joke
there to a girl that I knew
was a stripper and was going to law
school and she graduated this year from
law school yeah I'm not name her but she
did and so there for sure
her name is not porsche helvetica not
helvetica lost came up with that name
and I think it's the best stripper name
ever
what's the word on this helvetica come
on hello took a pill medica my god
helping someone who's a pelvic on
something I don't like it's a little on
the nose on the something
thank you ah yeah thank you
hi I'm Bethany i'm from san diego my
question is for Rose and the producers
what's up with the way can we expect
eventually maybe a full bleach Rose go
complete zombie you mean come in my real
life
yeah my hair is like a bale of height
it's like hot glued on my head it's so
fragile
it's like rubbish this would just snap
if I tried to Rosewood be bald in real
life just like any of us what exit area
among the
because he actually dies his hair was
the hell is that doing that obvious is
you are the first season I said to the
boys it was crazy because Malcolm had a
tragedy and his barbershop in LA and
like me Buckley role and mouth were it
literally like dudes just like talking
about hair like to show us pictures bro
what's up dude he's so upset and me we
sorted out but then a few days later I
go in and got my hair dyed and i ran my
head and threw my hand through and it
was snowing on my head and I was like it
hurt my scalper and I was like dude in
that same text change i was like bros
next time you look for me do not look
for david anders look for young and
Harris is going to happen look I gotta
think I'm most upset to just learn that
I'm included in these two it like the
book tix chains with the boys that are
just full of toilet humour and like just
real rubbish i get liftoff
the one about here that you can we got a
serious and even when we were there for
four roses a major trooper with the way
because she has to wear that for like 10
hours a day so she's already pretty
badass for just put up with it
given a couple head massages after work
when she really needs it and we do have
a new week this year so haha out
no I don't want you working on it and i
also have an incredibly difficult scalp
i have like really sensitive skin so it
I feel so sorry for the department i
mean they just can't really put any glue
so things on my head because it's
explode so yeah it hasn't been an easy
one to work out and I think they've done
a great job and we're really excited
about season 3 how the Whigs gonna look
we think it's gonna be even better
I also have to say that face is there
and you're looking at the wig i really
don't know what to tell you I have no
response to you kind of theirs that it
the wig it brings up an interesting
question because no one at fillmore
Graves has your look has the zombie look
and and they all believe in tanning and
dying like tan and I and they actually
get will get on your case about go
undercover as you ever handler you think
maybe or try it i don't think so i get
one here's the thing in it and it would
make a lot of creative sense for live to
try to blend in now and yet the whole
show started with the head of Warner
Brothers television development handing
me the comic book and showing the front
cover and saying this is the new heroine
for the CW go write it and and that look
like you are our poster and that that
wig and that hair and how do you just
how to play hot girl exactly what i was
going to sign one of my favorite hangout
don't like about this whole show this
experience is when i get to come and
meet the fans because you guys are the
reason we can do our jobs we are so
grateful it's like it's an honor and we
like interacting with you on twitter and
in hearing your thoughts but when i get
to see people dressed as live it's just
like it's it's we we filming this vortex
we're just on set and we're creating
this thing we don't even really know
what the outcome is gonna feel like and
then we get to kind of see that it's
impacted people and that people care and
and want to dress up like her and want
to dress up like a girl who isn't the
kind of girl next door every woman like
she's our own thing and she's eccentric
and a striking look and I feel really
really proud to be associated with that
I love that she doesn't try to fit in
she embraces who she is i actually
listen to David Bowie as the music for
love I don't even if i told you that
I've always listens like that's my
soundtrack because there's just
something about that embracing your
inner freak and that being what sexy and
beautiful about you so I don't live to
change all right right here
hi I'm Madeline I'm from Southern Oregon
hey Matt hey David we grew up next door
it's true we had shared a garden and my
dad a garden walk through the garden and
then we walk into her backyard which had
a pool
yeah he learned how to swim in my shirt
yeah yeah I thought you said this
message I thought this was eid hi I'm
I've also been told i'm the last
question
alright yeah um so my question is for
the actresses and the writers and with
the culture of feminism right now and
writing your show what themes and
responsibilities do you feel
come up for you when writing strong
female characters
Rob I'm what I mean it's an interesting
question because like we are one of the
things that we said going into this year
was we wanted a like we're gonna replace
Steven Weber with another big character
another guest Arne not necessarily the
big bad but a morally complex is
occupying the space that we used to have
a big bad and and we wanted her to be
tough and powerful and badass but you
ask yourself the question I are at least
I do is a writer then would if she if
she turns out to be bad then
are you tired are you right in a cool
empowering female character are you
riding a bad guy but I think it's cool i
think it's good you know it's but it is
something that I that I struggle with is
you know if she is badass and she is
smart and what if she does some evil
things is that empowering female
character on TV
answer anyone I know I just think a lot
of times more were writing or consent is
always in my head and I always feel this
weird pressure and you can just go down
that rabbit hole and then if you go
fully down the rabbit hole you never do
anything and it's also kind of hobby
also disrespectful because then if i
have to worry every time I write
something and I'm making women look bad
and should not be worrying about making
me look bad and i just write women like
people and not give a shit
so ah you know when I was doing the
stripper episode I was like this bad and
then I thought well there's women out
there who are strippers
I didn't invent it didn't invent like
this it's just just writing people as
honestly as you can and trusting that if
it's the end of the day people have a
problem with it a woman wrote it and
she's an EP and she got paid and she's
fine with it so I feel like I'm i think
actually having you know over various
pilot seasons and looking at different
jobs of the several hundreds of acted
like character descriptions practices
and it's like they're just there were so
many that were like the the wife of the
governor over the daughter of and that
was boring and then there was so many
that were like tough badass that was all
they were and that's just as boring
that's not that's not a complex strong
interesting character to me what I liked
about what how these guys right and I
said I mean you can see it in Veronica
Mars you see this show in various
characters i think like this power
invulnerability and is the being a
multi-faceted interesting female who can
be really strong and also can be
incredibly weak and need things that's
not something that we should be shying
away from that something that it's
tonight it's a four men and women and I
think sometimes we start to write these
really or I have to read scripts of
these really stereotypical kind of tough
chicks and I just I mean personally I I
feel like that's not my idea of true
strength i think like being able to
embrace you are in for whatever that
means is ultimately the the kind of goal
so i feel like these guys have written
the character where I'm not afraid
sometimes to need help i'm not afraid to
offer help
I you know she's on her own journey and
that's again not the driving force is
necessarily trying to communicate
something that plays into everybody
else's ideas but just communicate a real
person with real feelings and and not
not perpetuate and ideas that we don't
believe it you know
and Madeline I drove by our houses the
other dare old houses they're still
there i miss him
I'm gonna text you later okay